فرنسا تغازل بوتين
هل هذا مؤشر لخيانة
وطعنة في الظهر الأمريكي...
ألم يحن وقت الثأر والانتقام
من خيانة أمريكا وأستراليا لفرنسا؟،
كيف يقطع الأوروبيون
اليد الأمريكية في منطقتهم؟
لماذا لا يقبل بوتين الحوار
الا مع الطرف الفرنسي؟
لكن مهلا دعونا نفكر لثواني،
لماذا فرنسا؟
أليس هناك بديل آخر تلجأ له روسيا؟
أ لأن هناك ثأر قديم وصفقة العمر
التي خطفتها أمريكا من فم الفرنسيين؟..
ماذا عن جيش الاتحاد الأوروبي؟..
هل يمكن أن نرى قريباً هذا المسمى
يخرج إلى النور؟
كيف ستحل الفوضى على الحدود بين بولندا وبيلاروسيا؟
وهل تستطيع الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
تنفيذ تهديداتها ووعودها
الوقوف ضد روسيا حين تغزو أوكرانيا؟
الصورة العامة هي أن الجميع يتفقون
على النقطة المركزية:
يجب القيام بشيءٍ ما إذا كان لأوروبا أن تبقى آمنة.
عام ٢٠١٨،
خرج الرئيس الفرنسي إيمانويل ماكرون بخططه
من السر إلى العلن،
وأكد دعوته لتأسيس جيش أوروبي موحد،
بعيد عن حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو) بقوله:
"لن تحترمنا الولايات المتحدة كحلفاء
إلا إذا كانت شؤوننا الدفاعية ذات سيادة.
لهذا، على أوروبا بناء استقلالها كما تفعل الصين".
الجيش الأوروبي ليس خطة وليدة اللحظة،
ولم يأتي بها ماكرون من رأسه.
ظهرت فكرة إنشاء جيش أوروبي لأول مرة،
في العام 1950،
عندما أراد الأوروبيون وضع حد لمطامع الاتحاد السوفياتي،
لكن الخطة كانت وستظل حلما فرنسيا،
إلا أن أمريكا أحبطت هذه المحاولة سريعا
في عام ١٩٩٩،
وذلك بسبب وجود حلف الناتو في المنطقة،
وفي عام ٢٠٠٧،
صدرت اتفاقية أوروبية بتشكيل الكتيبة الأوروبية المسلحة الأولى،
وستكون خاصة بأمن الدول الأوروبية
من الأخطار الخارجية،
لكن هذه الكتيبة ظلت حبرا على ورق،
"قوة الدخول الأول"
ماكرون وضع خطته مجددا،
وهذه المرة بما أسماها قوة التدخل الأول،
بهدف  تشكيل أول وحدة عسكرية عديدها
5 آلاف عسكري، مدعومة بسفن وطائرات حربية
ودبابات ومدرعات وأسلحة ثقيلة..
وفي العام ٢٠٢٠،
أخيرا اتفقت ١٣ دولة أوروبية منها ألمانيا،
على تفعيل خطة ماكرون،
بتخصيص ميزانية عسكرية خاصة
بقوات تقوم بحماية الاتحاد الأوروبي،
الجيش أوروبي سيكون مبنيا
لإيقاف التنين الصيني والدب الروسي خصوصا،
لكن يبدو أن فرنسا قائدة الاتحاد الأوروبي حاليا،
تريد إرسال رسالة غير مباشرة إلى حلف الناتو
بقيادة أمريكا. وتكون بذلك قد زرعت الشك
لانشقاق داخل حلف شمال الأطلسي،
وخرجت من عباءة الاحتياج لأمريكا في المنطقة،
لكن لماذا تريد فرنسا إزالة السيطرة الأمريكية
عن المنطقة؟
...
(الانتقام والأخذ بالثأر)
على الرغم أن خطة الجيش الأوروبي
قد مر عليها أكثر من ٦ عقود،
إلا أن فرنسا جددت رغبتها بتكوين هذا الجيش،
لإزالة تدخل أمريكا في المنطقة،
ولترد على خيانة  أمريكية  لها منذ وقت قريب...،
وهو ثأر لجرح حديث لم يندمل بعد،
ولم يمر عليه سوى سنوات قليلة،
أمريكا استطاعت إلغاء أقوى اتفاقية اقتصادية
تمتلكها فرنسا،
هي صفقة الغواصات
التي كانت قد أبرمت فرنسا عقدا ببيعها لأستراليا
مقابل ما يقارب مئة مليار دولار،
لكن أمريكا بطريقة أو بأخرى استطاعت
جعل استراليا تتنصل عن العقد وتنكثه،
مقابل أنها ستتكفل بإمدادها ببديل عن تلك الغواصات،
وهناك كانت خسارة فادحة لفرنسا
في الجانب الاقتصادي،،
لم يمضِ وقت طويل وها هي عجلة الزمن
تدور لترد فرنسا الطعنة لأمريكا في ظهرها،
بتشكيل جيش أوروبي بعيدا عن أي تدخل أمريكي،
وفي الوقت ذاته ففرنسا هي الوسيط الذي اختارته روسيا
للجلوس على الطاولة فيما يخص غزو أوكرانيا،،
ويبقى الشيء المؤكد هو رغبة أوروبا
بقيادة فرنسا لإنهاء دور حلف شمال الأطلسي
في المنطقة. ما يعني تهميش الدور الأمريكي أيضا،
ليهتم الاتحاد الأوروبي بأمور منطقته
ومنها مشكلة روسيا مع أوكرانيا،،
وبذلك فإن أمريكا يستحيل عليها أن تنفذ تهديداتها
العسكرية ضد روسيا إذا ما قررت الأخيرة
اجتياح أوكرانيا،
في ظل تفاهم بدأ بالظهور فوق الطاولة
بين روسيا وفرنسا،
والغرض سيكون هو بكل تأكيد
إضعاف الطرف الأمريكي بشتى الوسائل....
الجيش الأوروبي بدأ  كحلم فرنسي ففكرة فخطة،
ودائما ما لاقت هذه الخطة الفشل،
لكن هذه المرة حتى وإن فشلت الخطة،
فقد كسبت فرنسا نقاطا خارجية مهمة
ضد الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
فهل تعيد هذه الفكرة الأمجاد الماضية للدول الأوربية ؟
....